When something is escalating and tensions are rising and a table,
you and Gilbert are so gifted at that where you'll just say one or two things
and then everyone's laughing again.
Yeah. Yeah. Come on. We'll move on.
Um, but I know you're very good at that. I can't do it.
I ride the wave of tension. I'm like, Ooh, it's about to blow.
It's about to blow. I'm here for it.
You smile a lot more. When I feel you're uncomfortable, use fake smells.
This is busy, but you can tell what my fake smile is. It's just like this,
but I also sometimes forget that that's what my listening faces and I
hate it. Cause I've seen myself on camera and then I'm,
I'm trying to really fully listen and try. It's difficult to make me laugh.
That's a problem. Okay. We'll pretend laugh, babe. Like if you're,
if you're reading a scene and then you have to laugh, do you do it?
Can you do it?
Of course.
You have to do it now.
[Inaudible].
Hang on. Hang on. Let me try it. Hold on. It sounds really bad if I try it.
No, I think you just, you know, just how you do it.
You think of something that made you laugh.
Okay. I'm going to think of your goats. Sounds all right. Uh, hold on, hold on.
It's not coming out
right now.
You don't do it right now. I feel,
I feel like it's something that's going to disturb me.
It's going to disturb me for life. You do it right now. I'll be honest.
I don't think I've because I do it. You know what she did the other day though,
that she did do one and she did a fake laugh that made me laugh. So.
No, no, no. That wasn't a fake laugh. He says, what would I do?
So what I said was we were in the elevator. I said, what would I do?
What would you do if your son said, you, mom. You know what I mean?
You're a or whatever. What would you? Cause she she'd be strict.
And this is what, so I say that to me, Hey, you, mom, you are.
She did that. I need a medicine.
Met a sing laugh. Right?
Which made me laugh because it didn't sound like maybe it's not as fun.
It wasn't a laugh. It wasn't a laugh. I can't do it.
Have you ever heard of that?
No. Cause I've noticed some people will say something funny that you don't know,
you do like just smile and you kind of like, it's kind of like a polite thing.
Yeah. But you don't laugh when you laugh. Maybe you don't laugh, laugh.
Like we laugh. No, you make me laugh. No one on this podcast.
I've seen her laugh. She has. Yeah. She like.
I think you're, I think to this day in my whole life, there's no one.
Wait.
That's okay. So that to me is your real left. Is that fake? Nuts? That's fake.
But I see you do that so many times with it's always faking. I'm always baking.
Yeah. When people, when I do this and I've noticed a bit,
when I've got guests come out and I go,
I put my head up like this and I laugh sometimes. Right.
I'm not laughing, but I will say no,
because there's times I've seen you do the head thing,
but then you put your feet up. I know that's real. When you can start with,
it's not real. The feet thing. No, the only time,
the only time I can really really know when I'm laughing is when I did the, uh,
the goat noise. And then when she was laughing and then I started laughing.
That was a real laugh dude. Yeah. But don't tell that to the guests.
Cause I'm still going to cut this. No, don't cut this out either,
but that's just a, you know.
I think I have to learn this year.
Someone has to teach me how to socially fake laugh because,
and when I don't my face, is this just.
Do you, cause then people at least know with you. It's like, Oh, okay.
I don't like feeling when people's like,
I don't want anyone to feel that their joke fell flat with me.
Cause then it's just weird. And it happens all the time with me because he,
he has a, such a high level of comedy.
So when I meet everyday people and they try to like be funny around me and I'm
just so stone faced and I'm like, that's not even remotely funny.
That's not remotely funny. I love it. You're a cyborg.
Yeah. It's funny. It's when you know, I've, I've hung out with the other day.
I've hung out with San Tino. I hang out with guys, you know, Santinello a lot,
Eric Griffin. He doesn't. Yeah. Eric makes it laugh. Santina really.
Makes me laugh though. Makes me laugh. Laughs.
Because he's so I love watching Santino talk to other people.
He doesn't give anyone any room to say anything and he just dictates.